tu fais très bien les chroniqueurs
l'année dernière thé des premiers
chroniqueurs médecins à l'avenir du
comics je termine en disant lâchera et
termine
que en fait ce que font ce match que de
moi je m'en tamponne la cacahuète la
cacahouète gelée de ou la laine on a les
deux je pense que c'est bien de dire les
deux jours après que kawa merci pour
cette précision ainsi simplement sort
bien souvent même tu vois en fait je
plains encore mathieu mon enfance je
sais lamartine vraiment je plains
mathieu parce que quand tu as autant de
véhémence à la garde de quelqu'un est
versée ça traduit comme une souffrance
on nous donnerait une souffrance et
épaves ou les deux ont les deux mains
c'est vrai nous les deux c'est possible
mais tu vois moi j'ai pas attention peut
juger donc j'ai partir du 12 juin le
juge statue pas dire que je suis né là
d'excusés une mauvaise enfants je suis
un temps que je connais rien ce que tu
juges tout le monde à 2 prend pour un
génie ravet un charlot
des téléspectateurs des morts jeudi en
syrie quand je viens ici je viens quand
je viens ici j'ai pas pour mathieu pour
les uns et les autres cherchent à
écouter quelqu'un faire son titre
pendant une heure et demie je m'en fiche
que tu fais à chaque fois fait si tu
veux très bien mais moi tu vois ce que
je viens c'est devant les
téléspectateurs aux téléspectateurs ce
soir je dis quoi alors je dis allez voir
les chiffres de la drees il ya ainsi
quiconque est notable c'est des données
officielles allez voir effectivement sur
la semaine du 21 au 27 février allez
voir sur la semaine du 28 février au 6
mars et vous allez voir que bah quand on
vous dit que le vaccin protège des
formes graves et bien vous avez le droit
d'interroger ça et bien moi je leur dis
allez voir un médecin et une exception
les avocats et les coups sûrs dimanche
qu'il n'existait qu'à dit quelque chose
on est d'accord on est là merci mathieu
mais l'asie surtout pas voir votre
avocat mais allez réfléchir par vous
même ne laissez personne vous piquez la
réflexion à mener c'est pourquoi les
faire 16 ans d'études ou leurs designs
saison ces spécialistes n'importe quoi
se
disant bien sûr c'est cet endroit nous
et moi on est mal bas ne les ont percé
c'est énorme ce que tu connais connaître
facture doublé président rennais mais
c'est jane s'est dit renner six ans au
français qui nous regarde je voudrais
vraiment dire ceci ne croyer ni les uns
ni les autres ni les uns ni les autres
faites vous votre propre opinion mais
comment ils font surtout un médecin ils
sont
excuse moi vous avez des données
nouvelles anarchique non à la voir le
site de fabrice di vizio n'allez pas
voir le site complotistes que sèche
allez vous voulez arriver en société
allez voir les données santé publique
france allait voir les données de la
drees aller les voir aller les voir ne
regardez pas mathieu ou moi on sait les
gens ne seront pas les livres c'est leur
métier non mais maintenant que jamais à
son métier savent lire des chiffres à la
vie par exemple excuse moi tu sais
mathieu a dit fort sous toit et moi je
sais je suis comme un génie de détroit
va avoir une mauvaise enfants
je ne prends pas les français pour des
imbéciles
c'est tout et que les français ont une
intelligence suffisante pour aller se
faire eux mêmes tu sais quoi 80 sont
sortis